mm
obama et son double ironisant sur
l'impopularité du président lors d'un
dîner devant la presse américaine qui
nous moore est une constante lors de cet
exercice dont les présidents américains
sont coutumiers l'autodérision ont
choisi par obama en dit long sur
l'ambiance de sa femme mandat après tout
les espoirs qu'il avait incarné comment
le président américain répond qu'il aux
critiques actuelles ce grand communicant
at il gardé et son style qui avait fait
son succès et qu'elle trace quand il de
laisser à une petite année de la fin de
son mandat en prenant position de façon
inédite sur la question des armes à feu
ou du réchauffement climatique pour
répondre à ces questions et pour
déshabiller en tout bien tout honneur un
président qui même après sept ans
continue de surprendre avec nous quatre
invités bonjour françois durpaire
historien spécialiste des états unis
roxane frias journaliste américaine et
auteur de nombreux documentaires sur les
états unis pour la télé française
philippe lentschener communicant vous
connaissez bien vous aussi les états
unis où vous avez travaillé et enfin
marie virginie klein consultante
schilder alors vous avez scanner le
style obama afin d'en tirer de leçons
qui pourrait inspirer les politiques
français et c'est vrai que dans notre
pays où la participation des politiques
aux émissions de divertissement fait
parfois débat est bien le style obama a
de quoi poser des questions alors ce
style on y reviendra a beaucoup évolué
mais d'abord une constante la constante
de barack obama
sa façon de jouer avec son corps sa mise
en scène corporal très visible
dès 2007 comme ici dans l'émission d'une
animatrice qui s'appelle hélène
voilà lors il est dense bien voilà et
puis elle sait faire danser la famille
obama barack obama mais aussi michelle
obama comme ici dans une récente
émission c'était pour lutter contre
l'obésité
alors sa femme sa femme dans ceux ci
même sans lui mais qu'on ne s'imagine
pas que les années de pouvoir l'ont
dissuadé de continuer à exemple l'été
dernier dernier lors d'un voyage
officiel au kenya pays natal de son père
voilà alors c'est vraiment une constante
chez lui on aurait pu trouver d'autre
exhorte enfin bon on s'est limité à 3
pour montrer la palette est là bas y
était alors m'arrivait de l'éclat à vous
qui avait justement étudier sa gestuelle
que pensez vous de cette constante cette
particularité qui persistent sur la
manière d'utiliser son corps on va
d'abord moi quand je vois ces images je
me dis une chose c'est barack obama
danse bien vous l'avez dit ce que ça
veut dire qu'ils dansent bien c'est
qu'il est bien dans sa peau il assume
totalement son corps il a des mouvements
souples
il est spontané il est à l'aise ça veut
dire une chose pour les personnes qui le
regardent ça veut dire je n'ai rien à
cacher je n'ai rien à me reprocher il
n'a pas peur du ridicule parce qu'il se
met en danger et danser comme ça c'est
se mettre en danger et oui c'est un il
n'a pas peur du ridicule et le message
qu'il envoie c'est je crois en moi je
crois en moi j'ai pas tellement moins
que j'ai pas peur du ridicule ça voilà
et je crois moi et en plus vous qui me
regardent et croyez en moi croyait en
moi parce que ce que je vais dire je le
ferai et je ferai ce que je dis c'est un
vrai message de transparence et de
sincérité qui renvoie à travers cette
gestuelle qui nous en tout cas dans nos
pays européens nous sommes tout à fait
tout à fait spéciale où est tout à fait
décaler parce qu'effectivement comme
vous dites y'a sega c'est ce danger
cette mise en danger qui à roxane fria
c'est comme ça que ces personnels et tu
te fais compris en fait cet américain
nous grandissons en faisons des danses
des cons et à la maternelle c'est voyons
n'est plus à l'aise dans nos cordes co2
européens et que de france excusez moi
je suis française aussi depuis peu donc
voilà vous avez compris
merci malgré le petit d'accent voilà
c'est ça il est à l'aise dans son corps
il est jeune aussi
il a une famille jeunes il y a deux
jeunes dansent aussi d'anciens docks qui
sont à l'aise ils sont confiantes et ça
nous fait du bien parce que nous les
américaines on regarde le président en
parler avec le divertissement
c'est pas les tables rondes auront
discute pendant deux heures comme en
france c'est par les messages qu'ils
passent sur le talk show où le petit
globe comme souvent on va apprendre
d'accord et où il fait passer comme dit
cette image de
conférence à l'heure sachant que bon il
ya le contexte américain vous l'avez
évoqué est quand même cette spécificité
de barack obama qu'on ne retrouve pas
chez chez d'autres à quand un gars n'ont
joué à très peu d'imagés du carter est
un élément vraiment de sens ira lui
diriez alors déjà effectivement il ya
cette dimension américaine par exemple
obama lé vous voyez souvent avec un
chewing gum j'ai toujours un chewing gum
sur les plateaux télé on dit enlève ton
chewing gum mais aussi le dit pas comme
il ya toujours un chewing gum c'est très
américain
mais on est quand même une rose aux
américains spécificité c'est à dire que
là effectivement y danse à chaque fois
il dit quelque chose de différent avec
son corps chez dans le ellen show il dit
c'est mister cool c'est le sinatra de la
politique c'est je suis à l'aise c'est
je suis bien avec mon corps michelle
obama quant à dans ses différents a fait
de la politique a dit bouger avec moi
puisqu'elle est en train de parler est
alors de son série dames en billons de
ces derrières etc
c'est de dire je lutte contre l'obésité
infantile juvénile et c'est lorsqu'il
est au kenya il dit
je danse avec vous c'est à dire que là
il est sur une danse traditionnelle cédé
juste eu au kenya c'est exaltant donc il
ya toujours un message différent mais il
ya toujours un message derrière alors il
ya effectivement la danse il ya
également le sport vous auriez pu faire
la même séquence avec pourquoi il nous
montre qu'il a fait un coup
extraordinaire sur le green à hawaï il
ya peu de temps
et puis il ya également la dimension
d'humour qu'on a vu il ya très peu de
temps on n'est pas dans le monsieur
petites blagues à la hollande c'est à
dire que c'est pas un rire est là et là
pour le coup mais obama on faisait pas
beaucoup la première année quand on
était à 10% de chômage et que
ben laden n'avait pas été attrapés etc
il n'y avait pas de blague
il ya eu plus de blagues ensuite il ya
eu plus d'humour mais le sketch que vous
avez vu là qui est réservé aux
journalistes de la maison blanche
ce sketch qui a été répété une dizaine
de fois donc là on n'est pas dans une
petite blague
on est dans un sketch qui dit des choses
politiquement un exemple il dit à un
moment donné lui le obama
le vrai il dit je remercie la presse
vous êtes formidables et c est derrière
le l'acteur l'accord dit merci à fox
news de faire peur à tous les petits
blancs
donc c'est des messages très forts à
violents on va revenir sur cette manière
de jouer puis sur l'autodérision mais
peut-être juste avant un petit mot
puisque vous dites que quelque part il
se libère aussi corporellement même
c'était une constante depuis le début un
petit mot l'action qu'il donne sa
playlist aussi d'ailleurs musicale sur
spotify donc on voit qu'ils jouent
beaucoup sur ses cadres s'ils n'ont pas
agi comme indiquant il n'empêche quand
même que lee carter ni bush ni clinton
et qui vous voulez ne le faisait ce donc
dire qu'il ya une spécificité
stratégique lourde et et elle est
consubstantielle à son élection
dire qu'il a été élu sur son attitude
plus que tout autre président américain
et qui avait le côté america is back et
là où c'était très très malin c'est
qu'en votant pour lui ont prouvé qu
américain était pas qu était de retour
et il a eu là dedans ensuite un style
jette dessus très confiant je suis bien
dans mon corps je suis relax et comme
les américains romance leur vie comme
les américains everything is
entertainment
il est tout en scène obligatoirement il
a réconcilié l'amérique avec elle-même
et l'amérique avec ce qu'elle est aux
plus fondane même fait de danse et la
comédie parce que c'est vrai comme si la
réconcilie l'amérique avec elle-même et
parce que l'amérique romance et met en
scène sa vie
l'amérique et sans contrainte l'amérique
et dans les espaces si vous regardez
toutes les chansons et les lie dans
cette ville de rawda ios et etc
il n'y a que du mouvement de l'espace et
il réconcilie les américains avec eux
mêmes avec d'ailleurs un petit piège qui
va le suivre depuis le premier jour qui
est qu'ils soient ce que les américains
l'ont nommé comme étant des nommés comme
étant motivateur in chief et qu'il ne
soit qu un motivateur et motivés il faut
pas oublier obama a vraiment grand
10 avec tout ce qu'on peut appeler le
sang chaud milhas sa compagne était le
premier fabricant de crowdfunding donc
c'est pas juste parce qu'il est
numérique 1 c'est une génération qui
s'est très bien manipuler le média
internet les blogs
il a comme j'ai dit deux ados ont quand
même deux filles ados donc il est
vraiment compris qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour la magie question personnelle
il fait partie de cette génération de
deux éducations alors vous aviez évoqué
les sketchs la mise en scène la langue
en a une qui est qui et nous a semblé
particulièrement intéressante à c'est un
spot pour l'obamacare donc cette réforme
controversée obligeant tous les
américains à souscrire à une assurance
santé alors qu'avant c'était privé
optionnel est donc dans ce spot pour
promouvoir le bas macaire est bien le
président mouiller sa chemise là aussi
fait pas mal d'exercice on regarde
nous
ouais voilà alors l'idée assez qu'on
fait tous des choses un peu en cachette
quand on se croit seul même barack obama
la question c'est un peu finalement à
quoi sert ce spot parce qu'il joue sur
plein de code il ya plein de choses on y
reviendra
mais qu'est ce qui fait passer avec ce
spot à la fin de mois nathan américain
la spécialiste
en fait je pense que déjà des offres et
de s'inscrire c'est très important c'est
deadline les 15 février
voilà il y avait une date butoir
effectivement pour souscrire c'est alors
aussi cers de c'est vrai c'est compliqué
et il a passé deux ans vraiment
communiquer ce qu il fallait faire et je
pense ce qui fait utiliser toujours
l'humour et il est en train de cibler
les gens ce dont ont besoin de plus de
cette campagne les jeunes les pauvres et
les plus âgés qui vont peut-être réglé
par internet ses messages etc
donc il se met à boire le placent aussi
je suis un peu bête je fais de salvi je
fais deux je fais des choses que vous
faites aussi devant les glaces
donc il est en train peut-être de durée
dramatiser l'idée de h cup même de son
message que c'est pas compliqué seul
s'il vous plaît et c'est un point c'est
pas compliqué parce que pour les gens
pour les américains c'est ça peut-être
qu'on a du mal à comprendre c'est
compliqué d'aller souffrir à l'obamacare
alors que c'est aussi simple que de
faire un selphy ou de mettre ou pas mac
mais c'est surtout lourds du masseur
avoir la balle de basket dans le panier
oui marie visionique a alors
alors pour moi le message de cette vidéo
c'est celui-là c'est je suis président
des états unis
mais je suis un homme comme les autres
d'une certaine façon le président normal
françois hollande en a rêvé barack obama
l'a fait il utiliserait son mandat parce
que ça sert et son rang et ils utilisent
plein de signaux du quotidien le cookie
dans le lait le basket pour se
rapprocher et crée une extrême à
proximité avec les américains notamment
à la fin quand il dit
iolo mène donc you love you only live
once une expression qu'on utilise je
crois un peu partout aux états unis qui
est l'expression vraiment très très
commune est donc là encore on a vu tout
à l'heure la danse
là on voit ce risque qui prend et se met
encore en danger en disant moi je mets
en danger parce que j'ai pas peur du
ridicule
j'y vais et je n'ai rien à cacher pour
moi c'est ça qui est important pour vous
donner une idée cette vidéo elle a été
vue 60 millions de fois
c'est un joli score mais aussi il est
bien entouré par des spécialistes parce
que on fait le tri n'est pas ce qu'on
sait faire et on est content des
conseillers programme fasse très bien
alors justement il est vrai ont visé se
sait si réussie parce que vous là on
voit le bas vous nous expliquer
effectivement parce que peut-être allé
un peu dans le coup ça a été dit 60
millions de fois la présidence normale
mais mais en fait il est quand même
resté à des taux de popularité y compris
quand les américains disaient sur le
plan politique c'est peut-être pas ça
mais en termes de sympathie l'a toujours
resté très austère la popularité parce
qu'effectivement il était il était
remonté à 50 % d'opinion favorable cet
été là il est un peu il est un peu
redescendue à 40% d'opinions favorables
c'est beaucoup moins enclines que qui se
disent oui mais c'est mieux que d'autres
présidents comme bush à la fin de son
contrat avec l'as qui as et kiala fle
font évidemment la forme là on est aussi
sur buzzfeed donc et une des plateformes
les plus importantes est aussi le choix
il ya une image dans l'image animée qui
est une image fixe qui va aussi buzz est
en elle-même c'est l'image où il se
prend en selphy avec la perche et ça a
été repris aussi énormément america
normal mais roosevelt c'est la radio
pour l'historien lequesne kennedy c'est
celui qui bat nixon à la télévision et
évidemment le cyber président c'est
barack obama qui gagne en 2008 là dessus
qu'ils gagnent tout au long de son
mandat mais évidemment il n'y a rien de
spontané tout est extrêmement travaillée
vous imaginez les heures la de de
travail pour cette rien de cette vidéo
sont dispo dans son verger à nouveau
mais la vision partagée dans le sport
qu'on se pose wallace et la stratégie
dans le dans le sport et surtout est-ce
qu'elle est efficace parce que notamment
quand ils jouent beaucoup sur
l'autodérision et à waimes alors
justement alors elle est fondamentale
pour moi parce que là pour une raison
l'impression qu'ils jouent beaucoup sur
la popularité alors qu'il n'est pas si
impopulaire que ça c'est ça le débat le
débat c'est l'horreur il faut vous
rappeler il faut vous rappeler que
barack obama a mis
ti plier les excuses pour les ratés de
sa réforme de santé
souvenez vous du débat américain au
forcing au sénat au forcing à la chambre
des dysfonctionnements partout là ce que
vous avez c'est un film où il lui rate
tout il conte il rate son panier le truc
ne rentre pas dans le vert et à chaque
fois il dit sphinx obama par contre le
jeune homme réussit où lui et vous avez
un parallèle et tomber son verre de café
partout où vous avez un parallèle entre
petit à petit lui obama qui continue
avec au total est de l'autoroute
dérision a raté ses trucs et l'autre qui
a donc le bénéfice de la santé qui il
bien être et donc l'idée c'est quelles
que soient les rater
quel que soit ce que je peux faire la
chose la plus importante c'est cette
réforme c'est votre bien-être à vous et
vous avez le parallèle entre les deux
d'accord j'en veux bien moi j'attends
locales et bien compris dans l'accord
donc l'autodérision c'est vous me
critiquer parce qu'il aurait quand même
été très critiquée par assange estimant
que l'ue est râpé et objectivement il ya
eu des ratés mais finalement ce qui
compte c'est pas mais raté c'est ce que
c'est le bienvenu et le bien et le
diabète de ce jeune homme
d'accord donc c'est intéressant sur
l'autodérision du obamacare en partie
parce qu'évidemment une partie des
américains notamment les républicains
sont hostiles mais du site également sur
l'a6 relationnel vous souvenez de cette
conférence de presse où il montre aux
journalistes et dire on va voir une
vidéo qui va expliquer obamacare est là
pour le coup la vidéo par pas mais c'est
intentionnel
1 ils se moquent évidemment dû rater du
site internet oui là il fait il a mimé
évidemment les rieurs de son côté et
c'est gagné
nashville obama tout est toujours
stratégie oui mais mais pas toujours
réussi à un petit autodérision peut-être
un mari visionique là parce
qu'effectivement ccc une dimension
importante il est pas si bas en fait
c'est intéressant ce qu'ont préparé
l'émission se divise et bayod il
vraiment tombé très bas dans les
sondages nord est on voit qu'il a
remonté et qui jouent cette carte de
l'autodérision peu tout en n'étant pas
si bas que ça c'est intéressant
vous avez un commentaire à faire
peut-être là-dessus il et c'est ce qu'on
a dit c'est la confiance
c'est le contenu aux épices et névian
sans lui d'accord et se sont dit rien
rien à perdre et puis va retrouver je
pense tout chambre qu'il avait tout au
début il va nous rappeler qu est-ce qu
il représentait pour nous les américains
et et voilà moi je pense qu'ils haïssent
et nous il est nous je répète il est
jeune et la jeune famille il est beau et
la famille qui est beau il a envie de
nous rappeler qu'il est en réalité ce
qui nous apprend ce qu'il représentait
en 2005 aux lionnes vont pas qu'on ait
une vision trop romantique pas valide
romantique non non ça s'est avéré siens
romance mais barack obama calcule tout
est stratégique surtout n'a élevé la
communication et la stratégie d'un art
ce qui n'est pas une critique mais non
non ce qui n'est pas bien de rester
collé gratuit je suis pas tout seul on
n'est pas des lourdement à déjouer
l'autodérision et là comme marque de
confiance et d'assurance lui mais il a
choisi 16 massage c'est un reflet de ce
qu'il est ce que c'est à dire c'est que
ces espèces ne sont pas uniquement ce
qui l'est c'est message c'est ce qu'il
pense qu'il faut véhiculer et on alors
et en cela c'est très bien et on se
lasse et savez bien le message
alors justement là on a vu on a vu
l'emballage on va dire maintenant on va
rentrer dans le dur des thématiques avec
aussi des manières de les traiter
assez assez spécifique alors est-ce
d'être alors sous le feu des critiques
on a vu pas de maintenant que ça ou
alors le fait de n'avoir plus à se
représenter qui désinhibe barack obama
en tout cas ils n'hésitent pas à aller
en cette fin de mandat sur des terrains
minés un des thématiques minet dans une
société américaine ou le port d'armes
est en droit et après avoir échoué en
2013 à faire voter une loi
le limitant ce droit au port d'armé bien
il continue barack obama à s'en prendre
avec virulence aux armes à feu lors de
chaque actualité tragique un exemple ici
en octobre après une fusillade sur un
campus de l'orégon evans
le garde des sceaux a déploré les morts
est une routine dit il mais ces réponses
ne le sont pas en janvier il présente
une série de mesures dans un discours où
son émotion s'exprime cette fois par des
pleurs ou tard
m
sow
alors un président qui parle et qui
essuie ses larmes c'est une image
évidemment complètement inédite alors il
ya eu beaucoup de critiques aussi là aux
états unis va notamment sur certaines
chaînes steam foxnews on l'accusé
d'avoir fait exprès de pleurer dans la
communication alors justement philippe
fonctionnaires vous qu'ils disaient que
tout était communication chez lui on
n'est pas dans la tête de barack obama
bien sûr mais pour vous ses larmes c'est
quoi vous les recevez comment je suis
incapable de juger sincèrement je ce
dont on peut être sûr c'est qu'il veut
faire un immense moment de gravité et
qu'il veut rendre ça important en plus
il a un vrai problème de par sa
situation minoritaire faso face aux
forces politiques qui sont dans les
chambres il a perdu il rêvait d'enlever
les gens d'afghanistan il reste cinq
mille personnes là bas ils rêvaient d'en
finir avec l'europe et du coup ben là le
problème on en revient sur scène je vous
ai dit que le motiver shon le motivateur
une chiffe risquait de nous tenir
longtemps dans cette réunion
dans cette émission pardon c'est que il
est condamné à forcer le trait très
lourdement à mettre des charges
émotionnelles extrêmement forte pour
lancer des débats parce que il n'a pas
le pouvoir législatif de réaliser les
choses et de dire il faut faire ça donc
obama il faut bien comprendre une chose
c'est qu'il est coincé entre deux trucs
d'abord une dernière année qui va
ressembler un tour d'honneur et ensuite
le fait que ce qu'il ne peut faire c'est
que lancer des débats et il faut savoir
ça ne lui fait pas peur parce que une de
ses idoles est un des modèles qu'ils
revendiquent constamment ses lincoln et
lincoln il aime à répéter que sur les
rapports égalitaires entre les noirs et
les blancs
il a fallu cent cinquante ans après ce
que lincoln avait avancé donc obama
lance des choses lance des pistes créée
des débats les pose sur la table et il
espère que le plus tôt possible
ils pourront se résoudre sur le port
d'armé il essaye de faire passer quand
même des décrets présidentiels
il a poussé le congrès oui mais il a
réussi là pour le coup parce qu'on se
posait la question de savoir s'il avait
réussi tout est alors là pour le coup
aujourd'hui on arrive à un fin de
deuxième mandat avec 75% des américains
qui souhaitent qui s'est alors qu'il
dise on est attaché au deuxième
amendement on est attaché au port d'armé
qui souhaitent que des ces textes on a
parlé d'un obama qui était le cyber
président là pour le coup ses
communicants c'est le quatrième siècle
avant notre ère c'est aristote et platon
et aristote pour le pour le logo pour le
pôle pour la raison est là à chaque fois
qu'il prend la parole sur le port
d'armes il a trois arguments nouveaux
alors par exemple ça a été fait en
australie ont réussi et c'est la
dernière fois c'était ce droit à porter
des armes nous privent d'autres droits
la liberté d'être éduqué sans être
massacrés etc
et puis évidemment platon et le
l'émotion c'est à dire l'émotion
là il sait à quel moment il va faire
cela il sait à quel moment il va pleurer
peut-être un petit mot sur c est sur ces
images sur la manière de faire alors
pour moi la communication d'obama elle
est depuis le départ basé sur
l'intensité
alors on parlait du silence tout à
l'heure là il s'est arrêté dans le
premier discours 800 avec ses fines
émises et extraordinaire s'arrêter cinq
secondes au gré d'une phrase c'est
extrêmement rare dans le premier extrait
avec 5h30 slater on voyait qu'il ne
parlait pas pourtant le hangar
translater parlait mais qui est ce qu'on
regardait c'est barack obama qu'on
parlait moi j'ai envie de dire que
barack obama c'est le roi du silence
il a une gestion du silence qui est
d'une maîtrise exceptionnelle que j'ai
rarement vu chez d'autres personnalités
politiques
la deuxième chose juste pour rebondir
sur les larmes d'obama alors elles ont
fait énormément débat chacun il dit que
c'est fait exprès ses fins ou alors que
ces signes delà de la faiblesse de
l'état
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ça
vraiment je le dis je ne suis pas du
tout d'accord avec ça pour moi barack
obama d'abord c'est parce qu'il est
puissant
en tant que homme que président des
états unis qui peut se permettre vous et
je pense que il marque un tournant dans
la communication qui est majeure c'est à
dire que il
des tâches des symboles de puissance de
pouvoir de domination de ce que tu est
intouchable que doit avoir un homme
politique parce qu'il a compris quelque
chose
il a compris aujourd'hui un homme de
pouvoir s'il n'avait pas ses capacités
d'empathie donc empathie se mettre à la
place de l'autre pleurer avec l'autre
ses capacités d'empathie de connexion et
de proximité avec les citoyens il est
impossible aujourd'hui d'exercer le
pouvoir sans ses capacités là et là il
le montre et il le dit et pourquoi il le
cacherai rien je me le dit alors il le
dit attendez je vais vous aider la côte
à côte dans la ville art
il a les larmes ont monté neuf personnes
sur dix les aurait retenu lui il a
choisi de les laisser couler parce qu'il
s'est dit pourquoi est-ce que ça serait
signe de faiblesse alors à l'horizon
parce que voilà il faut qu'on avance
il faut il faut qu'on avance je suis
désolé cela dit on a évoqué les
thématiques et on a parlé de la manière
on n'a pas de l'émotion de la mise en
scène il est aussi sur un sur une
thématique compliqué on l'a dit et c'est
vrai qu'en cette fin de mandat
on a l'impression barack obama va
souvent sur des thèmes on va dire qu'il
crève la société américaine puis dérive
a aussi ses se lancer dans des réformes
qui n'a jamais lancé jusqu'à présent
exemple lorsqu'il propositions sur le
réchauffement climatique avec là encore
des réformes est en voyage en alaska
mais voilà ça rappelle un peu le yes we
can des débuts et ce discours
s'accompagner d'une image sa
participation à une émission de télé
réalité où un fameux animateur lui
faisait découvrir la vie sauvage du
grand nord
voilà encore à ce qu'on balle pour le
climat risque de n'être que symbolique
vu l'opposition au congrès mais le
président semble aussi vouloir jouer sur
ce registre des symboles par exemple
lorsqu'il reçoit le pape en visite
officielle c'est son premier voyage aux
etats unis
après cuba le peuple françois est
arrivée sur le territoire américain pour
une visite historique de six jours pour
l'accueillir
le président obama en personne tout
sourire
sa femme michelle et leurs deux filles
sasha et malia
barack obama était visiblement très
heureux de saluer le saint père pour qui
il a beaucoup d'admiration
voilà là on a l'impression qu'un peu
deux ingrédients donc on l'a dit des
thématiques un peu controversé
et puis de symboles aussi qui joue
beaucoup sur les symboles ils essayent
alors la seule sur le climat ils
essayent de réussir là où bill clinton a
échoué c'est-à-dire qu'il ya la cap 21
oui enfin plus que tous les autres
présidents qui l'ont précédé en matière
d'écologie ya la coop 21 et 3 mois avant
trois mois avant il lance son opération
à la fois de communication et politique
pourquoi parce qu'il sait que si les
américains se disent l'écologie ça nous
est imposée par des institutions
internationales et ça nous est imposée
de paris ça marchera pas donc il va
faire cette émission running wilde où
ils montrent que l'écologie c'est mark
twain ses sauces et emerson ces
américains et que le mode de vie
américain ben c'est l'écologie c'est
aussi la colonia nature c'est exactement
ce que vous savez que le congrès dans
seulement peut bloquer obama mais peut
bloquer tout traité international donc
il s'est très très bien que là il joue
l'opinion contre le congrès ça marche
plutôt bien il va chercher aussi le pas
françois n'est pas françois qui vient
faire un discours également sur
l'écologie cette semaine la sueur sur le
climat est donc là évidemment c'est
aussi une thématique qui va passer au
successeur parce que on va le revoir
le bilan d'obama il va échouer sur le
successeur d'obama est ce qu'il va être
démocrate ou républicain voilà c'est ça
son bilan fin à ce qu'il essaye de faire
passer aujourd'hui c'est aussi des d'une
manière
de lancer le prochain candidat démocrate
bien sûr oui et alors sur les thèmes
justement roxane trial sur les thèmes
sur lesquels on croit entre le port
d'armes à feu là le climat des thèmes
qui divisent la société américaine
pourquoi les sur ces thématiques
spécialement à la fin de son mandat
parce que je pense qu'il a envie de
sortir avec le très tôt il nous a
tellement promis au début sur
l'immigration par exemple je crois il
est très très déçu qu on n'arrive pas un
résultat sept problèmes de notre système
d'immigration
je pense qu'il envie de sortir avec des
victoires parce qu'on était il est
arrivé si haut avec cet espoir
comment tenir cet espoir ya qu une
direction d'y aller voilà donc il a
envie de sortir avec des victoires et
une fois dans l'histoire des victoires
symboliques des thématiques parce que là
c'est pas des victoires sinon non mais
je pense pour moi ya pas que les sujets
sains ils imposent aux états la
fermeture de il ya des dispositifs
politique guerrière avec les actions
exécutif il a fait quand même 1 en 2012
et en 2014 pour les immigrés en disant
qu'on y reviendra
paraît il est en train d'utiliser son
pouvoir au caire c'est comme un passé et
ça marche
donc on pense coup de choses négatives
il ya des choses qu'il a fait qu'ils
sont en train de marcher et à les
éduquer les américaines sur
l'environnement
c'est pas par des speechs et des tables
rondes s'est pas mis les émissions de
plus populaires qui est diffusée dans le
monde entier
la réalité c'est qu'il a résolu le
principal problème pour lequel il a été
élu en 2009 il y avait 10 % de chômage
il y en a 5 quasiment le plein emploi
aux états unis tant qu'ils pouvaient pas
se permettre de lancer le climat dès
janvier 2009
aujourd'hui les américains il ya un
point sur lequel sont d'accord c'est
quoi comme viva que l'économie va mieux
c'est pour ça vous dit qui peut aller
sur ces terrains pu miner plus
controversées faites non parce qu'il
sait très bien que son 100% de chômage
c'est à quel prix il sait que le taux
d'emploi real il est égal à celui du
début des années 80 il sait que la dette
montre il sait quels problèmes de
classes moyennes justement pourquoi il
va sur c'est même pour ces sucres est ce
que il s'est fait élire
il voulait changer le monde et il a vu
que redéfinir le monde ce n'est pas si
facile que lorsqu'il avait des théories
donc le fameux notamment lead from
behind eh ben il a vu que le lead from
behind a été vu dans son opinion
publique comme étant du déclin et ça
s'est heurté aux réalités liszt bahreïn
s'étaient ce n'est plus à nous
physiquement d'aller imposé et d'avoir
un impact sur le terrain par contre
c'est à nous de faire que le monde se se
se dirige
d'une certaine façon à l'arrivée les
lignes rouges ont pas été respectées que
ce soit les alchimies bachar el-assad et
c'est donc tout ça ça a explosé alors
aujourd'hui son problème c'est ne
l'oubliez jamais il est jeune et il a
décidé que ce n'était pas fini à dix a
dit combien ça veut dire qu'il peut très
bien être
il peut diriger la cour suprême plus
tard il a d'autres objectifs et la
lincoln en tête le 150 ans donc ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui dans sa dernière
année on mais il veut être celui qui
aura tracé les lignes fondamentales
historique pour les américains de façon
à ce que derrière il était le
visionnaire loeb qui sera une icône
parce que il aura été le visionnaire des
états unis et il peut diriger la cour
suprême à ce moment là il peut faire un
certain nombre d'autres choses
commencent à évoquer les questions
d'immigration et c'est vrai que là pour
le coup elle a eu un vrai échec
un vrai échec au congrès c'était fin
et alors je voudrais qu'on regarde la
manière justement monte il présente cet
échec et dont il en tire les leçons
là on voit qu'il s'inscrit dans la
tradition des présidents américains
c'est pas une majorité c'est le
président malgré ces échecs il ya aussi
un engagement très personnelle qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs dans son dernier
discours sur l'état de l'union
pour son ultime discours sur l'état de
l'union lors du bilan pour barack obama
après deux mandats présidentiels
sous les yeux de son épouse michelle il
tient une allocution résolument
optimiste sur le plan international
barack obama s'est félicitée de la
normalisation des relations
diplomatiques avec cuba et réaffirmé sa
volonté de fermer guantanamo
la manière de gouverner dépend de la
valeur de nos exemples c'est pour ça que
je vais continuer à travailler à la
fermeture de la prison de guantanamo
c'est cher ce n'est pas nécessaire et
cela c'est uniquement de brochures de
recrutement pour nos ennemis encore une
promesse qui n'a pas été tenue et dont
il fait maintenant un combat personnel
mais quand dans son discours il évoque
quelques échecs et vendra justement que
ce ne sont pas les mêmes et un petit
aveu d'échec à mes enfants n'avait pas
désiré voit une petite concession et que
le reste du bilan est quand même très
très positif et je serai plus et tu pas
réussi à travailler avec les
républicains donc c'est aussi eux qui
ont on a un coût et qui a raison mais ce
qu'il a l'air très intéressante jusqu'au
sol et à l'union c'est clair on a alors
pour le coup on n'a pas beaucoup de
marge de communication c'est quelque
chose qui est inscrit dans les
institutions américaines c'est l'article
2 de la constitution le président doit
informer le congrès d'ailleurs jusqu'en
1913 c'était un texte est élu or là
c'est très surprenant ce discours sur
l'état de l'union
vous disiez tout à l'heure normalement
c'est un discours d'adieu c'est son
dernier discours sur l'état de l'union
donc il doit dire voilà mon bilan etc
sauf que là ça a été un discours de
campagne
il s'en est pris à donald trump il s'en
est pris sans le citer il s'en est pris
à tête cousant disant faut pas taper qui
campagne pour le coach a des bons pour
deux 2 personnes hillary clinton et
barack obama pour quelles raisons mais
parce que il a une opportunité
historique qui n'existe pas depuis le
22e amendement 1951 jamais un démocrate
a succédé à deux mandats démocrate
or là il sait que son héritage dépend du
prochain obamacare ça a marché mais
héritage des obamacare 6 et 1 6 et 2 ne
compterait que ce sera samedi pierre
tarn ce qu'il a fait les décrets
présentés sur les armes ça sera mis par
terre
cuba je vous rappelle qu' il n'y a pas
encore eu l'embargo sur cuba il tuerait
pas lavés ya des choses à cette mise en
place et tricoter ça veut dire que la
même si hillary clinton on sait que
c'est pas l'amour avec hillary clinton
c'est quand même le grand paradoxe elle
qui l'a battu en 2008 et bien son
héritage dépend de la victoire d'hillary
clinton est donc d'accord du fait qu'ils
eurent détruit non pas huit années
démocrate à la maison blanche mais seize
années évoquera rien à la maison pour
d'autres il veut partir il va pas partir
comme tous les américains le font
prendre air force one et faire son tour
du monde d'adieu il va faire campagne
d'accord pendant les 12 mois pour
laisser natale amokrane au dépourvu d'un
petit mollet il ya quand même les échecs
qu'il évoque dans ces extraits donc la
réforme sur l'immigration qui n'a pas
réussi à passer à guantanamo ils le
disent qui devient un combat personnel
comment gère-t-il justement par rapport
aux autres présidents américains ce
passage entre à la fois le fait
d'assumer ses échecs et puis et puis les
allèles la posture du président qui
maintenant en 2d comme des combats
personnels on a l'impression qu'ils
seraient dans une tradition l'avancé
extraits avant que sam frias et puis je
vous laisserai le mot de la fin je vais
répondre mais j'en veux juste ajouter
quelque chose on oublie que c'était
quand même la première président à la
noix et je pense
il se sent très seul parfois et je pense
sincèrement qu'il s'identifie avec les
pauvres les noirs les latinos c'est pour
ça qui va sur ses thèmes maintenant ils
osent aller sur ce thème pour
je pense que vraiment pour les pauvres
pour les gens parce que il comprend
c'est qu'on me laisse au président qui
viennent de cette classe qui n'est pas
parvenu qui était pas à l'élite comme
une kennedy qu'il admirait etc
et je pense que il a toujours gardé ça
pendant tout son mandat mais il était
peut-être naïve et parce que ça c'est
pas beaucoup exprimé dans certains
commentateurs ont dit c'est maintenant
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il endosse le
costume du président noir justement
d'allant sur la réforme des prisons
l'immigration qui éludent oui parce
qu'au début on aurait critiqué m entre
aulnoye trop black et donc il fallait
être mesuré il ay là il a dit j'ai envie
d'être moi même
vraiment je crois ça il a envie d'être
lui-même de aller danser danser danser
des batailles qui compte vraiment pour
lui d'accord donc là il ya une vraie
évolution puisque rats une communication
crs qu'il aura changé parce que vous
dites est dans tout et communication
chez barack obama et lee pense à sa
trace
évidemment dans tout ça est ce qu'ils
meurent a marqué une rupture puis de
benchenane ça a été extrêmement bien des
lions toutes les missions jamais
quelqu'un d'à maîtriser son corps comme
lui d'accord lui a évidemment lusage des
moyens techniques d'une aide d'un
million de tweets sont échangé pendant
le discours sur l'état de l'union et
dernier petit point le conseiller du
président disait c'est mal partis quand
les gens ne regardent plus un président
à la télévision
or barack obama huit ans après les
américains continuent à le regarder à la
télévision
d'accord bon bah merci en tout cas pour
ces décryptage look suffit de regarder
l'émission pour avoir la halle la
conclusion merci à tous les quatre
merci à marie lebon à mathieu russes se
sont tous les deux pour m'aider à
préparer cette émission merci à brigitte
son dos qui s'est créée par pour la
montée on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à athènes et où je suis aussi
de public sénat pour voir et revoir
trouver des amis en lui